if whatever reason you can only get one
weight to train with say at home then I
recommend going with 25 to 30 of your
body weight because the perfect weight
for you is going to depend a lot on your
specific goals however this is a great
place to start particularly for
explosiveness and athleticism but it can
also do a great job in those other areas
as well so studies show that if you want
to improve your explosiveness then going
up to 30 of body weight is the highest
upper limit reason being because you
have to go slower to lift more weight
than that meaning you're grinding out
movements and not being explosive and
powerful and fast think of it this way
25 to 30 of body weight is the perfect
amount to progressively overload your
own body weight of course for that
explosiveness we're talking specifically
about explosive compound movements
things like a weighted jump squat for
example alternatively though if we're
talking about isolation movements then
this kind of weight is actually quite
good for offering a significant
challenge for things like dumbbell curls
and for compound movements that aren't
performed explosively this is actually
really good for building strength
endurance and this is really important
because how often do you need to lift
something really heavy once in life
versus lifting something slightly
lighter an awful lot of time